we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
let's go to our next caller from the 818
area code caller what is your name where
are you calling from and feel free to
jump right in with your question hey
David Sean I'm calling from Thousand
Oaks California I'm a fan of the Bernie
wing of the Democratic Party and one
thing that's troubled me about them
recently is a lot of people's like
refusal to talk about the Russian issue
in the trunk cabinet I think Calculon
see from secular talk medical like the
liberal gbenga notation like that I know
some people on cue ideas can I gloss
over it and it's kind of confusing me
because what I'd like to ask you is why
is it that a lot of people in the
movement whose goal is the elimination
of you know corruption in politics money
in politics why are some of them
uninterested in the issue of of corrupt
foreign governments influence over the
present very good brilliantly stated so
I don't I I don't know what Kyle or the
Young Turks have been saying about this
particular issue so I couldn't comment
on that specifically I can speculate a
little bit so look I've gotten some
emails from people who say hey Trump
Russia is nothing and many of them
happen to be Sanders supporters what I
think is causing some former Sanders
supporters to say that Trump Russia is
nothing in its a distraction is that
they may be sort of worried that if it
turns out that Trump Russia is something
that it would imply that Hillary Clinton
would have otherwise won the election
which might upset them because a lot of
Sanders supporters really don't like
Hillary Clinton and hey I voted for
Bernie Sanders in the primary and I
think Hillary Clinton Clinton is way too
conservative on many issues I still
voted for her in the general election so
I think that number one it would be
really important for Sanders supporters
to realize hey if you care about
corruption then you need to follow
through all leads that might point to
corruption and whatever the
repercussions would be or would have
been of Russian interference in the US
election if it did indeed happen we
should know what they are because it
relates to the sort of
gintama see of the president that's in
power that that's number one now there
are other people who have been
contacting me who say they don't believe
that Russian interference would have
changed the outcome of the election
that's fine right i mean we're talking
about two separate things here and the
collusion that may have taken place
between Trump and Russia is relevant and
it would inform the legitimacy of trumps
presidency regardless of whether it
would have changed the outcome of the
election so i think that there's
sometimes a misunderstanding of what the
issue is from some of the people that
deny there's a connection but yeah i
don't know how anybody could fairly look
at all the evidence right now and think
there's nothing to see here i also think
that there's a lot of people on the Left
who are thinking that Democrats are
putting all their eggs into one basket
and so if nothing really comes out of
the Russia story there won't be anything
to fall back on yeah that's kind of
while we're taking in above all approach
right all of the above because we have
to focus on Donald Trump's antics as
policies and yes the Russia
investigation is really big right not
only that we're also talking about what
Republicans are doing under the cover of
The Donald Trump public persona which is
taking away a lot of attention from all
sorts of horrible regulations you know
internet privacy rules etc so anyway I
that's sort of my general sense of it
yeah I agree a hundred percent it seems
like a lot of people out there just
don't really get you can be upset by the
regulations of the emails and the idea
that a foreign country led by and you
know and the authoritarian could have
displayed the voters absolutely all
right thank you for the call really
really appreciate it hope to hear from
you again